john with students still learning from
home parents may be looking for places
that offer hands-on learning experience
the high roller has a new stem activity
for students to explore
our bianca holman is there reporting
live to tell us all about it good
morning bianca
hey good morning hector you know kids
have been learning virtually all year
long
and they're yes you can learn virtually
but sometimes you just need to
experience it
in person you can do just that they've
got some great science technology
engineering and mathematic activities
right here featured at the high roller
and so i'm joined here by tanya who's
the general manager of the link so
trying to tell us what families can
experience
well what we have done is if you go to
our website you can pull up
a study guide that will help you to
guide your child
through an entire field trip that starts
at the link promenade fountain
takes you up into the high roller and
it's an aid for parents with all the
right questions to ask
and so on to get your child to think
about not only am i having a fun time
today
but i'm learning as well about
engineering wonderful
so this could be up to 45 minutes like
you said you start at the fountains
you're asking questions there 15 minutes
there and then a 30 minute ride
in the actual high roller and you're 500
feet in the air why was it so important
for you all to do something like this
well you know we are part of the
community caesars entertainment
and we understand how difficult it is
right now for everybody
the kids at home learning and we've done
field trips many many times in the past
with the school district
so we decided to give parents the
opportunity to be able to do the same
and get out of the house with their
children have a good time but also learn
wonderful so if you weren't as a parent
able to be a chaperone on those field
trips with your kids now's the time for
you all to do it together
and of course this is a time we do have
a lot of people who are out of work who
are you know pinching pennies to try to
save up something to
put on food on the table next week
during thanksgiving or presents for
christmas
so give us the pricing is it affordable
for families it is it's very affordable
for families if you come down and you
bring your nevada id
children 7 to 17 are 5.75
and adults are 13.75 children
under six are free so you can bring the
whole family for a very very low price
all right wonderful and like you said
parking is free you can pull up right
there in the back there and then park
and
enjoy a wonderful time and field trip
with your kiddo so of course we're going
to have all this information on our
website
we're going to send it back to you guys
in the studio how fun only here in vegas
could you have a fun field trip like
that thanks bianca